we begin this half-hour with the what's
become the talk of the art collecting
world contemporary artist Jeff Koons
holds the record for a work by a living
artist sold at auction but that could
soon change another artist David Hockney
known for his versatile body of work and
vibrant palate could well break that
record in November at an auction at
Christie's not long ago we sat down with
a British artist to discuss his life and
inspirations what brought you to
California long hearty movies I'd always
noticed the shadows in them so I knew
that was a sunny place his paintings of
life here would become emblematic of
West Coast culture and your fascination
with pools really began because of
California it's always an interesting
thing how do you paint water how do you
paint something transparent a bigger
splash an 8-foot Square canvas was
painted in 1967 I spent nearly two weeks
painting this another of Hockney's most
familiar images Beverly Hills housewife
it set a record for a Hockney painting
at auction when it sold for nearly eight
million dollars in 2009 but in November
Hockney could set an even bigger record
when his portrait of an artist pool with
two figures will go up for auction at
Christie's in New York the estimate
eighty million dollars would smash Jeff
Koons current record for a work by a
living artist his balloon dog sold for
fifty eight point four million in 2013
why do you think you've been so popular
over the years I like to think it may be
the space in the pictures mm-hmm you
don't know why things become memorable
if there was a formula for them there'd
be a lot more of them years old be
pretty cool to set the record although
he doesn't get any of that money it all
goes to the currency trader who's
selling the painting